the People's Republic of China has
changed a lot since it was founded in
1949 as a hardline socialist country so
much so that if Mao himself rose from
the grave he'd probably fall right back
into it in the 1970s China was a country
of very very poor farmers and well now
it's a world superpower and economic
powerhouse no country in history has
grown so fast or has gotten so many
people out of poverty as China has done
in the last 40 years throughout this
time this country has grown as an
average rate of almost 10 percent per
year and most importantly almost 800
million people more than the entire
population of Latin America Spain and
Portugal have escaped poverty
[Music]
but I'm pretty sure this isn't news to
you or anyone else
but how did China manage to change do
you think that this entire
transformation was the result of a
carefully drawn plan some intricate
strategy mapped out by China's leaders
well dear viewer I think that this story
has a twist that is probably going to
surprise you so listen up by the way
before we get into the video today I did
want to thank everyone who has been
supporting us on patreon in just a few
days we've got 650 of you on board
helping us out in making these videos
we're right now working hard we're
preparing a lot of surprises and we're
going to have great stuff in store for
people who are supporting us on patreon
consider doing it if you want it would
be cool there's a link in the
description below and let's crack on
[Applause]
on October the 1st 1949 Mao Zedong
proclaimed the existence of the People's
Republic of China he did this from
Tiananmen Square in Beijing and he did
so with a very clear slogan and that was
China has stood up
[Music]
however in the following three decades
that reality had changed a lot Mao was
rather obsessed with the ideology
willing to implant the societal model
that he had in his mind that's pretty
much any cost and among other things
dear viewer he thought the Beijing could
decide everything and determine the
future of everything how much to produce
what to produce how to distribute the
workers how many factories were needed
how the goods were to be distributed and
production etc etc etc and not only that
the other thing that was clear to Mao
was that any dissidents was a danger
that had to be eliminated and of course
as you can imagine these ideas in the
hands of someone with so much power and
so much stubbornness certainly had
consequences some studies estimate that
during the almost 30 years that Mao was
the supreme leader of China between 50
and 70 million people lost their lives
due to famine political persecution and
absolute poverty
and after 30 years in power after
collectivizing all of china's lands and
properties and brutally persecuting
millions and millions of intellectuals
academics and anyone who wasn't
comfortable with the regime well China
was plunged into misery a Cultural
Revolution wrecked devastation on the
lives of millions of Chinese people for
ten years the nation was reduced to a
state of barbarism xiao han an associate
professor at china university of
political science and law at that time
more than 80% of all chinese people
lived in miserable conditions famine was
common political terror purges were the
order of the day and the living
standards were comparable to that of
some countries in sub-saharan Africa and
all of this while Japan and the Asian
dragons of Hong Kong Taiwan South Korea
and Singapore were taking off enormous
Lee that's why we can't be surprised
that when Mao died in 1976 the Chinese
Communist Party divided into three very
different sectors the radicals led by
Jan Cheng Malzone Widow
ha Gyung Feng's moderate reformers and
the most aggressive reformers led by
Deng Xiaoping in the end after a lot of
push and pull and after making it clear
that China couldn't stay the way it was
any longer in 1978 it was the latter the
most convinced reformers who took the
lead
[Music]
a black cat and the white cat do you
remember the questions that I asked in
the beginning of the video well let's
answer the first one right now how did
China manage to change its course in
December of 1978 at the 11th Congress of
the Chinese Communist Party the
reformist Deng Xiaoping took over the
country's leadership then Xiaoping
argued that the ideological utopia that
had damaged China so much had to be set
aside and that they needed to commit to
modernization in fact you might already
be familiar with his most famous phrase
it doesn't matter whether the cat is
black or white as long as it catches
mice Jung Xiao ping and the viewer
that's precisely what he did for the
following 10 years because if we have to
say something it's that the reforms
weren't exactly very quick but you might
now be wondering well okay Simon but
what exactly were their priorities well
from an economic perspective we can
classify the reforms into three big
blocks agriculture industry and trade
and well it all began in the fields
we've already mentioned that at the time
China was fundamentally a country of
peasants
[Music]
while the agrarian reform D
collectivized the countryside and the
communes were suppressed and replaced by
the usual family exploitation model in
addition these so-called household
responsibility system was implemented by
which many decisions such as what type
of crops the plants what investments to
make what tools and gear to buy passed
from the government from the bureaucrats
to the families themselves and not only
that the peasants had to sell part of
their harvests to the state and then
could sell the rest on the free market a
completely free prices and that was a
huge revolution that this time the good
kinds
agricultural production soared and food
prices dropped while the peasants living
conditions improved a lot and the
results were good so Beijing decided to
apply similar reforms to the industry
sector that way the government gradually
transferred decision-making from
Beijing's ministries to government-owned
companies yes the decisions were still
coming down from the government but
let's just say they were working under
different criteria that way little by
little throughout the 1980s
government-owned company managers were
able to make decisions such as sharing
benefits among workers paying
productivity bonuses granting the
freedom to hire and fire employees
deciding which suppliers to work with
setting free prices and the list goes on
[Music]
[Applause]
it makes sense because who better than
the company's own managers to decide
what they need to work better well in
addition this was all the companies by
the legalization of private companies so
suddenly government-owned companies they
had competition and there was also a
trade reform in which little by little
China allowed foreign trade by largely
dismantling import barriers tariffs
however beyond agriculture the reforms
they did face a huge problem China was a
very poor country and of course it has
either capital nor technology so well
what did the government do well this
gets interesting
special economic zones
at the beginning of the 1980s China was
a very poor country it was closed to the
world and it lacked both money and
technology but what it did have was a
large workforce willing to work in
better conditions than the ones they had
in the countryside so under these
circumstances Deng Xiaoping government
decided for an experiment they didn't
want to completely renounce the economic
model that they'd inherited from mouth
but they did want to make something so
they made special economic zones in
areas where the communist system had
stopped working see in these areas
foreign companies could invest and set
up factories that is they had access to
the Chinese workforce that in itself was
a huge advantage but that wasn't all
they also had very few taxes relatively
little bureaucracy and no tariffs it was
essentially a small oasis for
multinationals in the middle of the then
hostile and hermetic People's Republic
of China
Beijing's idea was very clear bring
technology bring capital bring work
initially for special economic zones
were set up Shenzhen Zhuhai shall men
and Shantou these were so successful
that the authorities began planting them
all over the country
there's the case for example of Schengen
when this special economic zone was
created the area was nothing more than a
poor fishing village with just over
30,000 people today
it has 12 million inhabitants its GDP
will soon surpass that of Hong Kong
itself and it's one of the world
capitals of technology and it's all
happens in just a few decades
[Music]
do you know the company's Huawei DJI or
$0.10 well they're from this city these
economic zone success was so great that
we can state that they were the
precursors of China's opening the
Shenzhen special economic zone is an
experiment we need more time to see
whether it has gone well we wish it
success if it fails it will provide some
lessons dong Xiao Qing because folks
Deng Xiaoping initial idea was to use
these areas not to open up the country
but to gain resources so that the
government could maintain the old model
it's often thought that China's
transformation was perfectly drawn
designs and calculated by the Beijing
government however and this might
surprise you
it wasn't like this
the marginalist revolution we think that
the Chinese reforms were planned by the
Beijing governments but were they really
well you see after Mao's death China was
a wreck the last crusade of the
so-called great helmsman the Cultural
Revolution had left the country in
tatters Mao's Cultural Revolution
producer result opposite to what he
presumably intended beating many Chinese
to lose faith in their government
altogether Frank decoder a Dutch
historian who specializes in modern
China in fact it was during this period
the black markets began to spread places
where people tried to survive outside of
the system and that's also meant a very
important cultural change perhaps that's
why after Mao's death before the
transitions chaos some changes began to
happen automatically
for example while the government
continued to promote collectivized
agriculture some regions revolted and
decided to implement the family
exploitation system on their own even
though this meant breaking the law and
returning de facto to a private
exploitation system and of course as
this initiative started gaining more and
more followers Beijing government
finally decided to establish these
changes as state policies but it was
actually following these changes that
caused the change in society something
similar happens with private businesses
in the cities
[Music]
you see after Mao's death many young
people had been sent to the countryside
returned to the cities and since there
was no work they tried to sort it out
themselves and the government simply had
to accept it and suddenly private stores
began to multiply like mushrooms in
every Chinese city ending the state's
commercial monopoly once and for all and
in a way the same thing happens with the
municipal and regional companies which
began to emerge outside of state control
this led them to be the most dynamic in
China for years yes it's true Deng
Xiaoping 's government didn't stop these
changes on the contrary he ended up
implementing them as policies but as you
can see a large part of the change far
more than what we're often told came
from the bottom up and not the top down
by the way maybe that's why China's
transformation was so great and happens
in such a short amount of time by the
way before you go and beat us up in the
comments we do know that chomping was no
saint he was a dictator and without
going much further we can say that the
Tiananmen repression was his own doing
but now it's your turn
do you think China will end up ever
becoming a democracy well leave your
answer in the comments below as well as
in this survey and I really hope you
enjoyed their video please do hit like
if you did and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for brand new videos also
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider Media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine and as always thank you
for watching
[Music]